question did anyone else notice that
those who oppose this resolution are old
white supremacists the people of Oakland
voted or the city council of Oakland
voted
80 to call for a ceasefire one city
council member then tried to insert
language in it at least to just condemn
Hamas that she knew that it was not
going to happen that you know they were
going to actually not vote for this
thing but they tried to at least put a
little language in there just condemning
Hamas now I want to show you this about
45 seconds or so of the reaction of some
of the Oakland citizens when all they
wanted to put in to the thing they were
going to call for a ceasefire no matter
what was just a little mild condemnation
of the terror group Hamas enjoy there's
not been beheadings of babies and
rapings Israel murdered their own people
on October 7th calling Hamas a terrorist
organization is ridiculous racist and
plays into genocidal propaganda that is
flooding our media and that we should be
doing everything possible to combat I
support the right of Palestinians to
resist occupation including through
Hamas the armed wing of the unified
Palestinian resistance as an Arab asking
with this context to condemn Hamas is
very anti-arab racist the notion that
this was a massacre of Jews is a
fabricated narrative many of those
killed on October 7th ma'am your time is
up including children were killed by the
IDF an amendment condemning Hamas is
bald propaganda meant to thank you your
time is up to hear them complain about
Hamas violence is like listening to a
wife Peter complain when his wife
finally stands up and fights back
question did anyone else notice that
those who oppos this resolution are old
white supremacists there's been a lot of
atrocity propaganda raging from claims
of beheaded babies to mass rape Hamas is
not a terrorist organization just
because the US and Israel um deems it so
Hamas is a resistance organization that
is fighting for the liberation of
Palestinian people in their land okay I
don't think we need to par through all
the ridiculous things that those people
said and and it's another example how
Tik Tock and algorithms have broken
people's brains and our education system
has absolutely failed young people and
the how radical the base of the Democrat
Party has got but again I want to
connect this to where we started I'm
from the government I'm here to help the
Oakland government which has plenty of
problems in Oakland we're about to get
to that decides to vote waste a moment
waste one second of the day on a
nonsensical vote having nothing to do
with anything relative to the to the
lives of the people of Oakland then one
person tries to say something roughly
say I don't know Hamas not great people
and then these clowns get up there this
is a giant waste of time it is a waste
of
money